So we're at the start of what's probably going
to be a very interesting week and there are
compelling things and funny things going on,
one that's funny is funny not because Joe
Biden is the be all end all of fixing America
or anything like it.
But it's funny because it's a sign of just
how terribly the Republican Party has performed,
even for many Republicans over the last 18
months.
Joe Biden's approval rating in Texas among
Texas voters is higher than Texas.
His own Republican governor, Greg Abbott.
If you can imagine, the poll conducted by
the University of Houston Hobby School of
Public Affairs has Joe Biden at a 41 percent
approval rating in Texas, whereas the Republican
governor, Greg Abbott, is only at 39 percent
approval in the state of Texas.
Now, there's a bunch of interesting layers
to this story.
And I hope to get get to all of them or at
least all that I'm aware of.
The first is that Greg Abbott is going to
be up for reelection in the year twenty, twenty
two.
And there's talk of, better or worse, challenging
him.
We saw Texas closer in the November of 2012
presidential election than it's been in a
very long time.
And if these numbers remain where Joe Biden
is more popular than Greg Abbott in Texas,
it could be a really tough reelection and
it could be an opportunity for a Democratic
governor to actually win the state of Texas.
That would be fascinating to see now.
Second, this confirms that the high approval
that Joe Biden is experiencing nationally,
we saw it at 63 percent early last week or
the week before that is being supported not
just by Democratic approval of Joe Biden in
blue states, but it's also being supported
by higher than typical approval for a Democratic
president from voters in red states, including
the state of Texas.
And then the third aspect of this is that
right now, at least much of what Biden has
done and much of what his approval is riding
on is his coronavirus response.
I've been saying for weeks now, just move
forward with the one point nine trillion covid
relief package that's been proposed by Biden
and by Democrats.
Don't negotiate with these bad faith Republicans.
Let them all vote against it if that's what
they want to do.
And so far, Democrats are moving in that direction.
The approval numbers for Biden overall and
uncovered response and the support of the
covid relief bill to me signal that Republicans
are voting against the bill at their own peril,
if that's what they do.
What I mean by that is this covid relief bill
that Joe Biden and Democrats want is popular
enough with Republicans that if Republican
senators and members of Congress all want
to oppose it, they are taking on significant
political risk for doing so.
Now, one important caveat about Abbott's approval.
Some Republicans in Texas don't like Greg
Abbott because he did do a mask mandate.
So it's not all as simple as Biden has a higher
approval because Abbott didn't do enough.
There are people upset with Abbott in Texas
because he didn't do enough.
And there are people upset with Abbott because
he did too much, even though he did a massive
mandate.
It was basically toothless.
And it's sort of like the worst of both worlds.
But the point here is that even in Texas,
Joe Biden's approval higher than Republican
Republican Governor Greg Abbott's, and that's
more evidence that the country is crossing
party lines on what they want to see as far
as covid response is concerned.
And if Republicans become attached to we stood
in the way of covid.
And we stood in the way of you getting any
money, it could continue to massacre them
into 20, 22, and remember that under Donald
Trump, Republicans lost the House in twenty
eighteen.
They lost the Senate and the White House.
In twenty twenty.
They saw Georgia go blue and Texas go closer
to blue in the presidential election.
And the Republican Party really is at risk
here and especially now with Donald Trump
considering launching this new political party.
It is a very tender situation for the party.
We'll talk a little bit more later about the
willingness of the Republican electorate to
abandon the party and to go with Trump.
We have some new polling about that.
But as has been the theme with the Republican
Party for the last four years, much of this
is unforced errors.
This all goes back to if Trump had just let
Foushee run the show, had gotten behind guidelines,
had offered American flag masks for Republicans
to buy and where he would have been reelected,
Republicans would probably still have the
Senate.
Now we're talking about a Democratic president
with a higher approval rating in Texas than
the Republican governor.
Unbelievable stuff.